people sometimes here in the US stinks
cabins died but it grew in other parts
of the world and then that leaked back
into the latinus cabins that we have in
LA
most people in the rest of the world
don't expect Latinos in LA to listen to
Scout music or even know about it but
it's what we do
[Music]
my name is Clement Therese I'm a
musician producer I'm most of the guy
behind the biggest ska punk events we
have in LA I grew up running around in
the streets of Linwood Compton and South
Gate I got shot at a few times I got
mugged a few times if I didn't have
music and I didn't have a ska punk shows
to go to I don't know where I would have
been Latin ska punk has influences from
all over the place it's a genre that
collects bits and pieces of everything
from Jamaican reggae to hardcore to the
Mexican Latin Scott it's just a clash of
everything
Latin ska started popping up in LA in
the mid late 90s it was in the
neighborhood we had a hard time playing
legitimate venues that's kind of what
sparked me having to organize some of
these events because no one would do it
for us I think a lot of these Latino
kids in the neighborhoods are attracted
to ska music the way people dance the
way people dress they just find
themselves in that the rhythm really
gets you going it touches a lot of
people so a lot of these kids that go to
our shows it helps them find themselves
it makes them feel like they do belong
to something it's a very personal
connection to them
[Music]